pour mam a dit farah camara et sa
conjointe la vie c'était dossier depuis
qu'ils sont les heureux parents de
petits jumeaux garder bien au chaud dans
leur incubateur au chu sainte justine
même si les nuits ont été courtes
le nouveau papa de 31 ans affiche un
sourire chaleureux aux lèves montrait
bien plus à une vente très bien c'est un
garçon et fille la naissance de ses
enfants arrivés quelques semaines avant
la date prévue marque un nouveau départ
pour celui qui a été victime d'une grave
erreur judiciaire
la ville chez les enfants ça va beaucoup
beaucoup me réconforter ça va beaucoup
repensé on peut l'appliquer là trois
mois après avoir été disculpé dans une
enquête pour la tentative de meurtre
d'un policier du spvm dans parc
extension même a dit farah camara est
toujours en thérapie pour traiter un
choc post traumatique
l'ingénieur de formation qui est chargé
de cours et techniciens de laboratoire
n'a toujours pas remis les pieds à
polytechnique pas encore géré par free
mais je suis quand même en contact avec
l'école polytechnique et puis
voilà j'espère que je puisse me rétablir
plus rapidement pour pouvoir commencer
mamadi camara suit une thérapie avec un
psychologue s'avancerait bien et
j'essaie de le commencer à avoir
confiance en moi
l'écopôle technique qui m'a fourni assez
de dead c'est au côté psychologique et
puis mon avocat aussi donc j'essaie
quand même d'avoir des rencontres avec
eux mes excuses
je suis à lui offrait publiquement
malgré les excuses publiques du
directeur du spvm sylvain caron qui l'a
disculpé
l'homme devient anxieux lorsqu'il croise
des policiers
je peux pas très bien me promener comme
avant quand je rencontre des policiers
des agents j'ai quand même peur j'ai
vraiment peur mais je fais tout mon
possible de ne pas faire de troubles ou
alors de ne pas déranger pour se faire
attraper un coach dont je fais très
attention au fait les gestes posés par
les policiers lors de son arrestation le
rend qu'encore très difficile très
difficile parce que même un agent à côté
de moi j'ai je me méfie beaucoup chef se
comprenait c'est difficile quoi donc je
me méfie beaucoup
j'espère que ça va se régler à l'amiable
[Musique]
l'option d'une poursuite au civil est
toujours sur la table même a dit camara
affirme que ses avocats ont eu des
échanges avec la ville de montréal
vous savez il ya quand même un très bon
canal de communication entre et mes
avocats donc
je pense que la procédure suit son cours
depuis samedi son statut d'étudiant
étranger est expiré mamadi camara
bénéficie d'une période de grâce pour
régler son statut avec immigration
canada d'octroyer dans les plus brefs
délais la résidence permanente hammam a
dit farah camara trois mois après deux
motions adoptées à l'unanimité à ottawa
et à québec pour octroyer rapidement la
résidence permanente à mamady camara le
ministre fédéral de l'immigration marque
communs de chino l'a visiblement pas
utiliser son pouvoir discrétionnaire
pour régler le dossier malgré les
épreuves vécues
mamadi camara originaire de guinée
souhaite que le québec devienne sa terre
d'accueil et déjà je peux dire que les
montréalais les québécois ils en ont
fait beaucoup
j'ai reçu beaucoup de cadeaux pour les
bébés avant même la naissance mais
beaucoup beaucoup de cadeaux qui
j'essaie ils m'ont vraiment supporter et
je les en remercie pour ça et quand on
lui souhaite la santé pour lui sa
famille
ils répondent souvent on dit ça moi je
dis pas que c'est la santé avant mais
c'est la liberté avant si tu n'es pas
l'hymne situe en bonne santé c'est pas
la peine ici pascal à offida radio
canada montréal
[Musique]